what we're going to do in this video is
talk about modern campaigns in
particular we're going to talk about the
cost and the duration of modern
campaigns especially in the United
States and this graphic here which comes
from the campaign finance Institute and
it's based on data from the Federal
Election Committee it clearly shows how
the cost of congressional campaigns have
increased a mat dramatically since 1986
if you look at nominal dollars for the
House of Representatives so this is just
the actual dollar amount you see it's
almost grown by a factor of four or five
but even if you adjust it for inflation
the cost has doubled for your average
house campaign and you see a similar
trend in the Senate campaigns where even
adjusted for inflation the cost of your
average Senate campaign has increased by
50% now this also does not capture all
of the outside money things like super
PACs and whatever else if you fast
forward to 2016
your average Senate campaign costs a
little over 10 million dollars but
there's about that much money
approximately 10 million dollars that
also comes in from things like super
PACs and so it's totally near 20 million
dollars for Senate campaign on average
and so particularly competitive
campaigns can be a lot more than even
that and if you want to talk about
really big money you just have to look
at presidential campaigns so this right
over here is the last presidential
campaign in 2016 and you can see that
Hillary Clinton's candidate committee
money was over half a billion dollars
she actually had a good bit more than
Donald Trump and she had a good bit more
outside money but the entire Hillary
Clinton campaign had nearly 800 million
dollar budget and if you combine Hillary
Clinton Plus Donald Trump you have a
total of 1.2 billion dollars for the
2016 campaign in 1980 the total was 92
million it's more than a 12 fold
increase and even if you order it just
for inflation which these numbers are
not but new if you did you would see a
several fold increase in the cost of a
campaign so when you look at these types
of numbers
there's a couple of interesting
questions that come up one is what is
the money for money for what well
there's many answers to that one is is
that especially in a presidential
campaign and to a lesser degree in a
congressional campaign the campaigns
have to pay professional full-time
staffers so campaign campaign staff you
will often have a lot of volunteers but
for example Hillary Clinton in 2016
had approximately 4,200 people on
payroll we're about eight hundred people
were working directly for her campaign
another four hundred with the Democratic
National Committee and roughly three
thousand people with state Democratic
parties in the battleground states and
Beyond on the staff you also might have
paid political consultants and what do
all of these people do well they come up
with a campaign strategy some of them
will do polling to understand the
sentiment in the larger population on
specific issues or on the candidate and
they will do a lot of campaign
advertising and marketing advertising
and so the staff will think about well
what kind of advertising do we need to
do and then a large chunk of the money
actually goes to the advertising itself
advertising especially in mass media for
thinking about radio and television now
an interesting question is given that in
the 2016 campaign Hillary Clinton
outspent Donald Trump by so much how was
he able to actually win that campaign
well there's several possible
explanations to that one is is that
Donald Trump was very effective at
getting himself attention that he didn't
have to spend money for on top of that a
trend that has emerged really since the
2008 Obama campaign is the increasing
use of social media in campaigns before
social media became a major player most
of that energy really was in mass media
advertising but now with social media
you could cater a message to specific
groups you could focus your message you
can activate your base more and so more
and more social media which is currently
a lot less expensive than say TV
advertise
it's becoming a bigger and bigger part
of campaigns now the last answer to the
question of why so much money is that
you have long campaigns in the United
States in some countries the campaigns
might be anywhere from two to six weeks
in the United States the formal campaign
if you think about the first primaries
it's in February of an election year in
a presidential cycle and then the
election is in November so you're
looking at roughly nine to ten months
from the first primary and caucuses to
the election but well before the first
caucus you're going to have the various
candidates raising money and trying to
get name recognition and so the actual
campaign and money raising for a lot of
these candidates might be closer to two
years and so you can imagine if you're
spending two years with consultants
trying to do advertising just so you
have a showing in some of those first
caucuses and primaries well that's going
to cost you a lot of money now it's for
you to think about whether these are
good or bad things many people would
argue that having such a long election
cycle doesn't allow a lot of focus on
other things especially if someone's the
incumbent if they're campaigning the
whole time can they even govern and then
another argument against all of this
money is it might put too much influence
in the hands of people who can give
money I'll let you think about that